hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar validating single-cell RNA seats
data using single cell Western blotting
and RNA scope technology i am michelle
ashton of laberd's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by advanced
cell Diagnostics to learn more about our
sponsor please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor in the
presentation to do film simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab down at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window to follow the process to obtain
your credit
I now present today's speaker dr. Brian
P Herman the associate professor at the
University of Texas in San Antonio for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the BIOS you see tab at the top of
your screen dr. Herman you may now begin
your presentation
all right thank you very much everyone
for tuning in again my name is Brian
Herman I'm from the University of Texas
at San Antonio my laboratory is
primarily interested in studies of
spermatogenesis which is the process of
sperm production in the testes and in
particular we study the stem cells that
form the foundation of the spermatogenic
lineage and as a part of our work we
have done a considerable amount of
single-cell gene expression analyses you
begin to understand more about how those
cells function and how they're related
to other cells within the germ cell
lineage and the testes and consequently
we have been responsible for validating
our single cell data and so I'll tell
you a little bit about what my lab has
been doing at the single cell level and
how we've been approaching the
validation problem both in our published
work and unpublished work that I'll
share with you today using the Milo and
RNA scope approaches to validate our
gene expression results
first just to give those of you who may
be unfamiliar with the test s of a
little bit of a primer on
spermatogenesis this process occurs of
course within the test Asst and in
particular within structures that are
called seminarist tubules these are two
like structures that are repeating and
several of them were located within the
testa's and within each seminarist tube
you'll you'll find that the most
primitive germ cells are located closest
to the basement membrane on the
periphery of the seminiferous tubules
and as germ cell maturation proceeds
those cells move closer and closer to
the lumen where ultimately they're
released as mature sperm and so I you
can see in this particular cartoon that
illustrates a cross-section through a
seminal first tube you'll the complexity
of different cell types that are found
in any particular segment of a
seminarist tubulin and and so this
really underscores sort of the
experimental problem that we in the
spermatogenesis field are faced with
which is how to pin down the biology of
individual cells that are participating
in this lineage when the complexity of
the tissue is so high instead of give
you a greater understanding of the
complexity if we focus exclusively on
the germ cells we can see that
underlying the spermatogenic lineage is
as I mentioned earlier the stem cell
that forms this foundation and the
enables germ cells to be produced
throughout the lifespan of adult males
and so we call this all this format ago
niall stem cell and it can self-renew or
initiate differentiation to produce what
I call the rest of the spermatogenic
lineage but cells that will proceed
through mitotic amplification enter and
proceed through meiosis completes the
second meiotic division undergo
morphological differentiation to
ultimately produce
sperm that you can recognize as compact
nuclei with a flat f1 Gellin
and so this system is awesome in my
opinion because it gives us the
opportunity to peek into the process of
meiosis cellular differentiation stem
cell fade and has really strong
implications for understanding of normal
fertility pathology of infertility how
we can interfere with fertility and
contraception stem cell transplantation
in vitro culture systems for making
gametes and really there are many many
many more so we've been very interested
in understanding how the stem cells
function how they're related to their
most immediate progeny that we call
progenitors and and really how the
process of spermatogenesis
inner understanding so there's there's a
really ripe opportunity for expanding
our knowledge
but there's a problem and that as you
can see in this diagram that there are
many different cell types that we can
recognize based on decades of
experimentation in the testes but our
ability to separate those cells is
really limited so there are methods
available that will allow us to select
from at ago Nia that our mitotic or
mitotic spermatocytes around spermatid
and there are markers that can allow us
to select some subgroups of these but
what you'll see is that our ability to
resolve individual cell types is pretty
limited and so this limitation means
that we're going to necessarily
aggregate varieties of cells when we do
molecular profiling so this aggregation
of molecular analyses really poses an
important biological patient
so consider that a population of cells
may have a gene expression pattern
that's negative indicated by the colors
of the cells shown on the screen
those blue cells are relatively low
amounts of expression of any particular
gene and the yellow and red cells may
have higher levels but if you aggregate
those cells
the result is that you get a population
level result that constitutes the
average across the entire population and
so when you look at the average as shown
by the the Green Line this plot below
for the gene expression signature of
that particular population the result
doesn't match at all either of the major
populations known found in the bulk and
another example would be for a
relatively rare population of cells the
results from those particular cells will
be diluted out by the majority and so
the bulk average looks exactly
unlike the cells of interest
so this challenge really serves as the
foundation for needing an ability to
assess gene expression at the individual
cell look so the solution that my lab
has taken through this problem of
aggregation as well as a number of
others in the field of spermatogenesis
and in many other fields is to look at
gene expression at the individual cell
level across their entire transcriptome
so we have isolated testicular biopsies
from human patients as well as adult
mice and immature mice and isolated
cells from that particular tissue
including unselected populations that
include all the cells within the test as
well as various sorted cell populations
that enrich for particular cell types
and then profiled these cells using
single-cell RNA sequencing using a
couple of different commercial platforms
including the 10x genomics and flu x b1
platforms and then use sophisticated
data analysis pipelines to establish
clusters of cells that differ in their
gene expression profiles and model those
differences and developmental
relationships in pseudo time and then
establish gene expression signatures
that show how those cells change as they
proceed through development and this has
really opened up a number of different
avenues of Investigation and expanded
our knowledge and how spermatogenesis
works by considering all the individual
cells instead of simply examining groups
of cells aggregate
these and so to give you an idea of the
kind of results that we have obtained
here is a t-sne projection going all the
cell's that we extracted from the adult
mouse tested though each dot on this
plot represents an individual cell and
you'll see that the dots themselves are
not located all in the same spot they're
scattered around not and that shows that
there are differences in their
individual self transcriptomes but
they're also grouped by similarity and
that's what establishes the coloring
which reflects how similar those cells
are to each other so individual clusters
are colored similarly and so we can
establish what are the gene expression
differences between individual clusters
and that's shown in this heat map that
just appeared for the right that shows
the top 10 differentially expressed
genes between clusters and this is kind
of meaningless unless you look at what
the individual genes are but if we look
at some specific genes that we know mark
particular cell types we can then
establish which clusters of cells
reflect which cells in the test and
that's shown in this diagram at the
bottom where I've aligned different
clusters for instance cluster 16 with
particular cell types so cluster 16
contains a differentiated spermatogonia
some of the earliest differentiating
so this includes the stem cell popular
this has allowed us to really understand
how germ cells within the adult mouth
test us in this case are changing and
their gene expression patterns across
that developmental lineage
but these results really
assume that the data that we've
generated reflect
bona fide single-cell transcriptomes and
that the data aren't artefactual in any
way and so we've spent a lot of time and
and others have as well validating our
single-cell transcriptomes and so for
instance we we've performed studies
where we mix spells from different
species in this case from human and mice
together before or performing our single
cell profiling and asked how often do
reads from mouse and human co-localize
which could only occur if we were
detecting expressions from a multiplet
that contained a droplet or such that
had more than one self one for me PC
any can see that there's relatively
infrequent multiplet but also then do
the transcriptome resolves for instance
the expression profile of particular
genes match the expression profile that
we have already known in the literature
or which can we can detect using
antibodies
so shown on the right are the profiles
for three genes BD x for which marks
firm sells data for which is the general
somatic marker and KCT d9 which appears
to be expressed for matta sites and
you'll notice that for each of these
genes there are multiple histograms
that we call violin plots that reflect
the expression level among cells within
that particular population so for
instance data for is essentially absent
except for cells within the last two
clusters cluster 15 and 17 are somatic
cells while DDX 4 is very highly
expressed and all of the other clusters
and there's a little bit of boil over
into the somatic cell question
so we we took these data and extended
them back and teach you into the testa
sand used immunostaining with antibodies
against data for DDX for kc td9 and a
related marker called Tron 98 another
germ cell marker to validate that the
protein was found in the same cell
population feature that we detected the
RNA for those markers in the single cell
study and long and the short of it is of
the results generally match up so our
expectation that prints kc9 is expressed
by spermatocytes matches the detection
of the G shown in red the gene product k
c9 protein is most abundant among four
mattes ice with your one layer off the
basis
so this is a great a great way to
validate that the results are telling us
something working but the limitation is
that this is extremely time consuming
it's low dimensionality and really
leaves a lot of information
unintelligible so we've also extended
our validation to a higher
dimensionality by validating these gene
expressions signatures at the at the RNA
level using in this case bulk samples of
intact testes from mice as the first
spermatogenic wave proceeds during
postnatal tests this development the
beauty of that system is that each
population of cells sequentially emerges
in development so we can detect the
signature associated with a new
population as it emerges and then go
back and correlate that with our results
that we obtained in our single-cell
analysis so for example here here are
qpcr data from testes that were obtained
from mice from postnatal day 6 through
postnatal day 30 and shown in this heat
map is the levels relative levels of RNA
for a panel of 33 genes that mark
discrete cell types in the adult test is
based on our single cell data and you
can see that at postnatal day 6 the
first 3 groups of genes which are color
coded to match the scheme that I've
shown on previous lives are already
present and so their their levels are
already abundant but subsequent
populations of cells begin to emerge
sequentially as you move from left to
right across this heat map and that
reflects their initial appearance during
the first four metagenic wave so this
allows us to then correlate the
signatures that we detected in single
cell at the RNA level with the same
expression of those genes during the
first wave of meta Genesis but the
problem is this this has
our singularity so we don't necessarily
know what cells are expressing these
genes because we've analyzed the results
in bulk so really what this means is our
primary methods of validation both come
with some compromises or really
limitations I would say so protein level
validation with immunofluorescence or
indirect immunofluorescence means that
we retain the singularity we can see the
detection of the protein at the single
cell level in situ but we lose a lot of
the quantification ability it becomes
semi quantitative at best and the
throughput is is considerably low down
down to two three or four markers at a
time and really the assumption is that
there's a congruence between the RNA
detection that we've detected at
single-cell level and the protein that
we're detecting in situ and that may or
may not be accurate based on the level
of post transcriptional regulation this
is a particular problem for us in the
germline where there's a considerable
amount of post transcriptional gene
regulation where particular gene
products may be sequestered and degraded
or preferentially translated or not
that's dope and in addition of course
the assumption is there are antibodies
that are validated that are available to
detect the gene product of interest and
many of the folks in the audience I'm
sure will will laugh when they test an
antibody and maybe it works and maybe it
doesn't and that's not a trivial
undertaking in a lot of cases and RNA
level validation at least the work we've
done in bulk retains the quantitative
information but and the throughput is is
really instrument dependent and be a few
genes or hundreds of genes depending on
the kind of technology you have but
necessarily you lose the singularity so
none of these is perfect and and really
can we validate single
so data without these compromises and so
that's the question that my lab has been
faced with and has used now a couple of
different technologies available from
bio technique to address this problem
the first is using Milo which is a
single cell Western blot system which
allows profiling of thousands of
individual cells at the protein level
for up to 12 proteins per cell in a
relatively short amount of time within a
day using antibodies that are off the
shelf and validated for Western blot and
to give you a sense for how this works I
begin with a suspension of cells load
them into a kind of wide like chip that
has a thin poly acrylamide gel layer it
on top and and then load the cells on 2
micro wells within that gel by gravity
settling and really this means that by
plus on distribution you'll fill a
subset of the available wells within
within a particular chip and and this is
dependent on how many cells you load and
how long you allow them to settle and
then lyse the cells within the well and
electrophorus the products in in one
direction into that thin pilot
acrylamide gel and then immobilize the
products with UV light which then allows
you to perform in gel western blotting
with antibodies of interest that you
have maybe validated with a standard
bulk or aggregate approach and then use
secondary antibodies that are conjugated
to fluorophores so that the gels can
then be imaged with fluorescence a tech
based techniques
so so really in a matter of just a few
hours you can get at single-cell
resolution Western blot data on
particular gene products of interests in
thousands of individual cells and this
is something that is facilitated by the
Milo and a microarray chip reader
so to give you a sense for what the data
look like
here is a scanned chip that came
straight off the the microarray scanner
from a Mylo experiment and you'll notice
that there are lots of dots that appear
in rows and in a subset of those dots
you'll notice that there are white
splotches and those reflect the
fluorescent signal from the Western
blotting of the proteins of interest but
then a lot of them a lot of those wells
don't have any or didn't have any cells
and so there's no detection of proteins
in the in the lanes below but for each
lane the amount of signal can be
quantified so the area under the curve
can be established and then plotted
according to the distance from the
center of the well and different
products can be Co quantified in in the
same sample so in this case I'm showing
you detection of GFP from GFP labeled
cells as well as an internal control
with an antibody against histone h3
which should be present in in all cells
in this sample so we used some of our
germ cells to begin understanding how
well this technology worked in the male
germ line and for that we sorted germ
cells that had a GFP fluorescent
reporter and put those cells on a Mylo
chip and then detected a germ cell
marker which is d/dx for one that you've
heard of before and so shown here are
three lanes of a gel that have DDX for
positive cells located with them in them
and these are detected in the alexa
fluor 555 channel and at the same time
we also in a different channel detected
two different proteins histone h3 which
is our internal control which is on the
bottom of this this set of wells as well
as tron 98 which is another germ cell
specific
occurrence so you can see that both of
these proteins were detected in the DDX
for positive cells and we can detect
Tron 98 and histone h3 together because
they resolve at different molecular
weights this gel
and since we have thousands of
individual cells I'm just showing you
three we can quantify the degree of
overlap of these markers and so shown on
the right are some tables that showed
that the degree of overlap between Tron
98 and DD X 4 and so among DD X for
positive cells 90% or give or take are
actually more than 90 percent are also
Tron 98 positive but surprisingly a
subset of the DDX of the Tron 98
positive cells are DD X 4 negative now
this isn't actually surprising because
we do know that there's not complete
overlap between Troy 98 and DD X 4 and
so really this this shows us that there
is both congruence and heterogeneity and
expression of these these genes
I also mentioned that we had sorted GFP
positive cells and so overlap between
GFP and DDX 4 is shown here and you'll
notice that we didn't do a particularly
great job at sorting the GFP positive
cells because almost or more than 2/3 of
those cells were gfp negative as shown
on the second row
but among d/dx for positive cells we do
detect a large proportion that are also
gfp positive cells surprisingly about a
third of the gfp positive cells were
negative for DDX for this was something
we didn't expect and is something that
we're we're currently following up on to
understand the implications of
so shown on this plot is a diagram of
the fluorescence intensity for one
particular well that was marked with
three different proteins but that's one
cell and so how can we understand the
degree of fluorescence and how it varies
across the population and the beauty of
Mylo and the analysis pipeline is that
it provides the fluorescence readout as
a degree of intensity of the protein and
the quantification of the protein
prosser your population so you'll see
that there's a log10 difference in the
degree of fluorescence intensity of the
d/dx for positive cells and the same
thing is true for Tron 98 and an even
greater variation in the level of
histone h3 so really this technology
arms you with a lot of information about
the degree of variation among your
individual cells of interest and and
could help better understand the
underlying biology that's driving your
your system and for us as has been very
informative in terms of to what extent
variations in the RNA then correlate
with variations in protein level and
which is important in the germline as I
mentioned earlier and I should give a
shout-out to Erik jab Bart who who was
very helpful in doing or helping us with
the analysis from this particular
experiment
so
provides some some really essential
information at the protein level that
allows us to quantify the degree of
variation among individual cells and at
the single cell level but
as I mentioned earlier we're very
interested in in how the tissue is
organized and so the spatial
relationship of cells that have
different levels of these gene products
is also important to us and that's why
we started our validation schemes with
immunohistochemistry so these are plots
that you've seen before that show three
genes in this case ID for DDX for that
you've heard of already and sox9 sox9 is
a marker of sertoli cells which are the
major somatic cell type within the
seminarist tubules of the test is ID 4
is is one of our favorite markers of the
stem cell population in the test is it
also marks spermatocytes as they're
going through meiosis but we're
interested in the in the expression and
insert oles in
the stem cell compartment but the
problem is we don't have a good antibody
for id4 and so interrogating this gene
at the protein level is problematic we
can do this for other proteins like sox9
and and DDX for and and correlate their
expression but with the mRNA levels and
establish their profiles spatially
within the test this but but we can't if
there's no antibody available or if the
if the protein is not conducive to
detection in that method so this really
is a limitation of the available in situ
technologies so we've instead turn to an
alternative and and this is just a
rehash of what I just said we've turned
to alternatives which is to back up to
the level of the RNA and see if we can
measure spatially the expression profile
of our genes of interest and for that we
have settled on using RNA scope which is
also available from bio technique
through their subsidiary ACD
in RNA scope is a technology that has
been around for several years now that
allows really robust detection of RNAs
at the single cell level and at the
single molecule level so that the
spatial location and levels of
expression of a gene product can can be
measured and so their technology is
based on a double the target probe
methodology the single signal
amplification and I'll go over this in
more detail in some subsequent slides
and then quantification either with
fluorescence or chroma genic approaches
and that allows the expression levels of
the genes of interest to be quantified
in a spatial manner and and this is
really as I mentioned a really robust
technology that allows mRNAs long
non-coding RNAs and even splice variants
of genes to be detected in C Chu and is
suitable for a wide range of sample
types from formalin-fixed tissues to
frozen sections to cultured cells you
name it n N and it will work
so the way this works is the tissue or
cells are permeable eyes obviously need
to be able to get the regions into the
cells so so this is not compatible with
with live cell detection the cells have
to be have to be fixed in some way or
holes poked in them and then the target
probes and c2 probes are hybridized to
RNA within your sample that is that
signal is then amplified and
subsequently visualized and and
quantified and the the foundational
technology for this approaches is this
double Z probe design where you have two
independent probes that are struct
structured in this Z like way each of
which binds adjacent to each other on
the target RNA within a 50 base region
so you have two adjacent probes that are
binding to your mRNA and onto that set
of probes the preamplifier will then
subsequently be able to bind and sew
along any given RNA you have the ability
to hybridize multiple probes and the
typical number of double Z pairs is 20
so they have 15 18 or 20 different sets
of probes that will bind at different
positions along the RNA of interest and
each probe then will allow the
preamplifier to bind to the vet double Z
and then allow the amplifier to interact
which then allows the either chromatin
enzyme or floor 4 to bind to that probe
allowing you to get highly sensitive
detection of that mRNA and importantly
if both Z's don't bind so each of the 25
verse of that 50 base region doesn't
find then you won't get the preamplifier
and amplification so the signal will
essentially be nil so that is
which is the specificity of this
technology and so RNA scope can
facilitate four-plex manual fluorescence
detection or or to flex chroma genic
detection or up to 12 flex fluorescence
detection with a serial rejection method
that I won't want to talk about at all
today
and I also won't talk about bay scope
which is a technology that allows you to
visualize very small differences in the
mRNA sequence like at junctions or
splice variants and such but what I will
tell you about is our experience using
RNA scope with the manual fluorescence
assay and so I'll first show you some of
our results with the most important part
which is our sets of controls so each of
the RNA scope assays comes available
with positive controls which are the
probe sets that recognize what you might
consider housekeeping genes so in this
case RNA polymerase 2 epitope role Pro
lil isomerase B and E BIC wouldn't see
and you'll notice in the upper left I
have some violin plots that show the
expression profiles for these three
genes among our single cells so you see
that they're widely expressed but not
uniformly expressed among among all
cells which is which is not uncommon in
the tested the the Fermata genic lineage
often does those things different and
regular somatic cells
but when we look in cross-section
through a segment of test s you can see
in this case there's a seminal first to
Buell in the middle that it's somewhat
ovoid so a little bit a circular but we
can detect RNA polymerase 2 PPI B and
you couldn't see in a good proportion of
the cells within that seminarist tubulin
if we were to zoom in I'm sorry I don't
have a higher magnification you would
see that these genes are detected at
single molecule of resolution you can
kind of see some of the speckled e
labeling for RNA pol ii but for really
highly abundant gens the the dots are so
abundant that they all merge together so
a great example is the acquittance II
where it looks like a hazy red label so
this gave us say confidence that our
tissue was of high quality and we're
able to at least detect these these
abundant and widely expressed
transcripts so is this simply background
well that was our next undertaking using
our negative controls and for that we
use a probe set that recognizes in
irrelevant dean the coli gap B gene
which is not expressed in in eukaryotic
cells and so in this case the the
labeling is essentially nil there's some
background autofluorescence meant Estus
that we can pick up primarily in the
white and green channels in this case
but is not
consistent with single molecule fish
labeling as we saw in the previous slide
so really the the specificity of this of
this technique appears to be pretty high
at least with these these positive and
negative controls so the proof of
principle though was whether we could
get self specific detection of genes
that we know are expressed in there in
particular types of cells within the
test Asst and so we went back to that
panel of genes that I showed earlier
where we could label for some of them at
the protein level box 9 and DDX 4 but
not ID 4 because we lacked a good
antibody so in this case we've detected
these three genes at the RNA level using
RNA scope so in situ hybridization for
ID 4 which we expected to be expressed
based on our single cell results in
spermatocytes off the basement membrane
and so the probe in white in the annals
all the way to the right show the dots
corresponding to ID 4 and you can see
that those cells are one layer of cells
remove the basement membrane and we do
detect I don't have a picture to show
that here we do detect ID 4 in very rare
cells on the basement membrane which are
cells of interest that the spermatic
o'neill stem cells
and importantly we also see that
localization of DD x4 or our germ cell
marker which is most abundantly
expressed in in the mitotic cell
population but also detectable in
spermatogonia is where it's supposed to
be as well as Sox 9 X 9 is the sertoli
cell marker and we see transcripts
detected in sertoli cell cytoplasm which
weaves in and out between adjacent germ
cells so pattern of labeling is very
reminiscent of the pattern of sertoli
cell cytoplasm which is very nice to see
so we've established the the proof of
principle this technique seems to work
so now the acid test was to look for a
gene that we have just recently
discovered as being expressed
exclusively in the stem cell population
and also for which no good antibodies
are available and so unfortunately
because of publication issues I'm not
able to share the gene name with you
today but this gene gene a we found was
exclusively expressed by a population of
cells that we think is the stem cells
and you can see the profile of mRNA at
the bottom right in the violin plot it's
expressed by a really small population
of cells in cluster 16 and other data
shows that that's that's the stem cell
population and so we we did RNA scope
for gene a together with c-kit which is
a marker of differentiating germ cells
and and you can see the peak it lights
up a good proportion of the germ cells
within the seminarist tubules but
importantly does not label gene a gene a
is a germ cell or the cell that is
labeled shown with the arrow head as
positive for gene a is a germ cell
because it's also d/dx for positive but
it's kit negative which suggests is that
undifferentiated cell so this is really
important
confirmation that the identification of
this gene using our single cell data has
pointed us in the right direction
towards a novel marker and we're
currently following up on on that
observation now
so just to wrap it up I'd like to give
you a few take-home messages to to think
about and again to stimulate any
additional questions you may have after
my presentations finished so I I think
it's clear many from my field and I'm
sure many other fields are beginning to
see single-cell RNA seek become almost
the standard technology to interrogate
any biological system and so if there
are commercial platforms and academic
level platforms available these data are
becoming very common and so is then the
need for validating those data so how to
do that well I think at the protein
level a really good solution is to do
single-cell Western plot because that
provides both the quantification and the
singularity and the ability to do so
with with ease that is is not as easy
using other methods like
immunofluorescence in tissue section but
let's say you're not really a protein
biologist and you care much more about
the mRNA well you can also validate
these data at the single cell level in
situ using technology like RNA scope
that provides single molecule detection
by fluorescence in situ hybridization
that's quantifiable and again retains
that singularity that was really the
basis for doing these experiments in the
first place so I think the the toolbox
for taking single cell RNA seek to the
next level is really becoming much more
full and and there are technologies
available that will allow you to very
easily and and quickly move from the
discovery phase through validation move
on to what many of us are most excited
about which is to really get at the
basic fundamental biology under
our biological systems so with that I
will thank you very much for your
attention and point out first that there
are people that did this work I'd like
to take credit for everything but I
didn't do this work and it was people in
the lab here in San Antonio that
performed the bulk of this so Victoria
Diaz did all of our RNA scope
experiments and shin Suzuki has done a
lot of our bioinformatics
experimentation of course it takes
others to help out and so I should
acknowledge John the Kerry and his
postdoc Curran Chang who were
instrumental in the the single-cell
studies that are already published and
of course without money we wouldn't have
been able to do any of this work and so
I should acknowledge the sources of
funding in particular the NIH the
Clayburgh Foundation who funded some of
our single-cell work and UTSA for their
tremendous support of our genomics core
in which these equipment reside so that
thank you very much and be happy to take
your question
Thank You dr. Herman for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for all
right let's get started our first
question is is it possible to get a
microarray like data can we check a set
of proteins instead of one with this
technology
that's a good question so the Plec city
of the Milo profiling for proteins is I
believe limited to twelve and that's
going to depend on on a couple of
factors number one the kind of
microarray scanner that you have
available to scan the stain slides but
also the compatibility of the antibodies
to be able to work together so some of
the example data I showed had one
protein detected in a particular color
channel while others had more than one
examines detected and when you have more
than one protein or antibody for that
protein in a particular channel they
have to be separated by a certain amount
of molecular weight I would have to
defer to the my low technical reps to
help you with the specifics but in total
I believe twelve Plex for a given slide
at any particular time as the limitation
now I also believe that these slides we
haven't done a lot of this so I'd really
again have to defer to the Milo folks
but these slides can be stripped and
reap robed a number of times I've heard
numbers up to eight eight or nine times
which means that if you multiply the
number of reap robes by Alexa T you can
get quite high dimensionality data with
the single cell Western blot RNA scope
on the other hand the standard version
two fluorescent detection method is
four-plex
again this is going to depend a little
bit on the kind of detection
instrumentation you have so your
microscope may or may not be able to
handle four colors at one time in
addition to the Dappy channel so that
will depend on on what you have
available there is also
a high plex technology which is 12 probe
sets at a time and that would use either
three colors at a time or four colors at
a time again depending on what you have
available instrument wise so yeah you
can get some pretty high dimensionality
data I would not bring it to a level of
a microarray but I get considerable
breadth of a protein or RNA assessment
in a in a sample at a given time
great thank you all right next question
how many proteins can be detected at the
same time with this technology also are
there any protein sets that you custom
design and provide
I kind of answered that first part just
in my previous answer but to get to the
point about custom sets I think again
this is going to depend a lot on the
kind of antibodies that are available
for the protein do you want to probe I
believe there are a whole panel of
antibodies that have been validated by
eight by Milo or customers that the
representatives can point you towards
and you might want to check with with
the technical support people for
specifics but in general it's been our
experience that any Western blot
validated antibody tends to perform
pretty well using using the Milo
approach so I suspect you'll be able to
combine antibodies of interest based on
your own experience or if you don't have
antibodies already identified that the
Milo folks can can help you identify
those
thank you okay this next is a two-part
question I'll start with the first how
well our marker is known for the
numerous cell types in a thermogenic
lineage yeah so this is kind of the
underlying problem that we have faced
there are a number of very well-known
markers that are known to be expressed
by particular cell types in the
spermatogenic lineage but most of them
mark very broad population so it they're
really not suitable for nailing down the
biology of specific subsets of
spermatogenic cells so that's why we
undertook this set of experiments to
identify markers that would allow us to
resolve at much more high resolution the
particular cells that we're interested
in and in particular here the the
spermatogonia stems
right the second part of this question
was did you uncover any potentially
novel phenotypic markers in your
sequencing experiments that you were
able to validate on Milo or RNA scope
yeah absolutely in fact we we identified
so many that we have something able to
follow up on all of them but I did show
some some of our preliminary data for
gene a which is a protein that or
encodes a protein that has previously
not been reported to be expressed by the
stem cell population but which we are
now following up on in more depth based
on the results from our RNAi scope
experiments that show it is localized at
the RNA level at least to a small subset
of undifferentiated spermatogonia and
and based on colocalization studies that
are really still ongoing
it looks like it's restricted to the
right population so you know this is a
great example of where we could not have
validated that particular marker using a
protein assay because there aren't good
antibodies for it so our our strategy to
go after the RNA in situ was very
helpful
great thank you how do you validate an
Avion Milo and do you have a positive
control or STD so
I mean a couple of things come to mind
here
I think obviously validating antibodies
is a tricky business in any kind of
assay and I always tell folks in my lab
to use the best positive and negative
controls they can so if there are known
cell populations that you that you know
don't express the protein of interest
certainly include those in an experiment
you can do side by side or settle cells
that are positive for that marker on one
side of a chip and cells that are
negative on the other side of the chip
it's not it's not perfect but it will
give you a sense for whether that
antibody does does perform in in the
Mylo experiments standards so molecular
weight standards you could load
normalize known proteins that will take
away some of your your ability to use
all the channels but but that's
certainly possibility is something that
we asked when when we started doing
these experiments could we get a better
measure of the molecular weight of the
detected proteins and you know it's
really really kind of tricky so I would
say it's not not something that we do
routinely especially for very well
characterized proteins but it is
possible
thank you another two-part question how
easy are the single-cell Western and RNA
scope workflows to perform and how much
assay optimization was required for your
sample so I'm I'm a PI so I sit in an
office all day and so easy is much
different for me than it is for folks
actually doing the work
so my answer may be a little bit biased
I think these are very easy technologies
with the both the Milo and RNA scope to
utilize by labs that haven't haven't
gone down that road before
we've done some optimization for Milo so
that actually surprisingly worked very
well on our first shot and we we simply
had to settle on a an appropriate
settling time and that would be suitable
for our cell types so that we got the
right number of wells filled with cells
but besides that I think having high
quality antibodies is is the biggest
barrier so you know if you have
antibodies that are very well
characterized that you have good
experience using then more than likely I
would say you'll have pretty good
success with the Milo we do use this
instrument as a part of a core facility
and we have had customers that have
struggled with particular antibodies of
interest but we've been able to point
them in the direction of some
alternatives that have worked better for
them and given them good data so that I
think for Milo has been pretty easy to
adopt for most people
RNA scope is is equally robust so when
we started using RNA scope for in situ
hybridization we had been struggling for
several months to get alternative
technologies working without any luck
and on the first time first try we
followed all of the guides were
preparing tissues for sectioning the
tissues to enhance the likelihood of
success and I should say ACD has done a
fantastic job of establishing those
protocols so go on their website and
download them and read them and if you
follow their their guidelines you will
have the kind of success we did which
was just extraordinary
we have not yet had any a probe that
hasn't worked and and people find that
hard to believe but you know I'm I'm not
overselling this it it has been a
marketable success for us
you okay next question looking at the
transcript and their gene products do
you generally see a strong quantitative
correlation between protein expression
and mRNA across all cell types you
looked at
this is a question the answer is really
dependent on the stage so in our
experience in Fell's with the test this
within the test is those that particular
spermatogenic stages really phases
stages the different a different
component of our our system so at
different points along their
developmental progression have different
susceptibility to post transcriptional
regulation and there and we know where
those are and so there are some some
genes that we've looked at that do not
correlate very well at the protein and
mRNA level and there are others that are
highly correlated so it really depends
on on the the stage at which you're
looking in the spermatogenic lineage now
how how to go back and and address the
discrepancy I think is really system
dependent so so for us an example is a
gene that encodes a receptor tyrosine
kinase kit that particular gene we know
is expressed at the mRNA level and there
have been a number of studies that have
shown that in the undifferentiated
spermatogonia but that don't turn on at
the protein level until those those
cells see retinoic acid to induce their
differentiation and there have been
studies that have gone back and shown
that that treatment actually or that
been exposure actually forces the mRNA
to the polysome fraction and enhances
its translation so this is that's a
difficult question to address and it's
really highly dependent but in cases
where the mRNA and protein do directly
correlate then that's an easy output
great thank you
looks like we have time for one more
question what kind of sample preparation
protocols do you use to get single cell
suspensions of your samples for
downstream single cell Western analysis
so just about all of our experiments
start with tissues so we will take
testicular tissue and use enzymes to
digest that tissue into a single cell
suspension most of the time that
involves a triptych enzyme to cleave
protein so we'll use trypsin and and
generally tissues don't like that so we
often include some DNA to digest any DNA
that that arises from life cells in some
cases we have to add collagenase enzymes
to digest basement membrane proteins and
in invariably we have to strain our cell
suspensions to get rid of debris and
clumps of cells and depending on what
we're doing we may do that more
rigorously than others so down to us a
35 micron strainer or something like
that but in general that that seems to
work well for for both the single-cell
RNA seek and the Mylo and of course for
RNA scope we don't need to do that
because it's the intact tissue
thank you again dr. Herman for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank flappers thank
you we would also like to thank
labyrinth and our sponsor advance cell
Diagnostics for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and further interesting
questions any questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on-demand laberd's will alert you via
email what it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye